شاهدوا العربيه والحدث اينما كنتم اهلا
بكم في هذا الحوار الخاص مع رئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقالي الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
البرهان هذه المقابله تاتي بعد توقيع
اتفاق اطاري حرك كثير من من المشهد
السياسي السوداني نقف على كثير من
التفاصيل مع الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
البرهان اهلا بك
سعاده الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان همم
طب انت كثير من القوى السياسيه ان هذا
الاتفاق لم يتجاوزها لكنه تجاوزها
كما انك تحدثت كثيرا انه لن يكون اتفاقا
ثنائيا
التحيه لك والتحيه لقناه العربيه والحدث
تحيه للمشاهدين والتحليل الشعب السوداني
فعلا هذا الاتفاق لم يتجاوز احد حتى الان
وهو مفتوح ومطروح للجميع
اللحاق به ليس تبع ولكن قضايا
الاتحاد الديمقراطي
يعني وقع رغم ان من وقع همم عضويه مجمده
في الحزب الا تشعر ايضا ان هذا التوقيع
يحدث انشقاقات اكبر داخل القوى السياسيه
توافق اذا كان داخل القوى السياسيه او
داخل القول سياسيه همم والعسكريه همم
سنزعل لكمال هذا التوافق بين هذه
المجموعات ونزع الاستكمال توقيع القوه
التي نرى انها ضروريه ان تكون موجوده في
ساحه السياسيه
[موسيقى]
الاتحاد هذه همم مؤتمر الشعبي اسعار السنه
هذه هي هو همم اضافيه واضاف حقيقيه للقوه
اللي كانت همم
همم من العناصر الرئيسيه لثوره ديسمبر او
كانت مشاركه حتى ابريل 2019
الشعبي بانهم ايضا ليس مع هذا التوقيت
ومصلحه الوطن مصلحه السودان اذا طلعت على
هذا
السياسي والاعلان الايطالي لن يتردد في ان
يكون جزءا منه لانه هو يعالج مشكلات
السودان وليست لدى احد من المواقعين عليه
نيه لاتصال اي من المكونات التي اتفقنا
عليها
25 اكتوبر الى ما قبل 25 اكتوبر
او مين مارس او ابريل 2019 حتى الان همم
ثلاث سنوات
الاربعه اعوام همم مررنا فيها ومره فيها
الشعب السوداني والقوه السياسيه والعسكري
بتجارب اذا لم نستفيد منها همم
بحتنا نضيع هذا البلد وسنضيع مواطنيه همم
لن يتكرر ما كان يحدث في الماضي لا اظن
ذلك هل ما حدث كان خطا اتحدث عن 25 اكتوبر
ما كان ربما مخفيه على الجميع الان نحن
نستشرف ما قبل 25 اكتوبر اللي يتجنب
مسببات ما حدث غير 25 اكتوبر اذا هو مفيد
وهو ضروريا حتى نضع الجميع في الطريق
الصحيح
25 اكتوبر كان خطا سياسي ربما هذه وجهه
نظره ولكن نحن عندنا على هذه الخطوه انه
مقتنعين تماما همم بضرورتها
باهميتها وهي الان من ثمار اننا الان نضع
اتفاق بصوره جديده معنا همم اصحاب المصلحه
الحقيقي هو خارج القوه كانت موجوده تلك
الفتره يعني عفوا هذه القوه القوه
السياسيه هذه رفضت من حيث المبدا ان تنضم
الى هذا الاتفاق ما هي الجهود التي يمكن
ان تجعل هذه القوه التي تراها انت ايضا
ضروري همم
تقديم الشرح الوافي المقنع للحاق بهذا
الامر اريد ان اسالك عن نقطه وردت يعني في
هذا الاتفاق اقامه سلطه مدنيه بالكامل دون
مشاركه القوات النظاميه نقطه اخرى تتحدث
راس الدوله هو القائد الاعلى للاجهزه
النظاميه القائد الاعلى هل هو مدني ام
عسكري
بالتاكيد نحن نتكلم عن سلطه مدنيه كامله
اذن الجميع مدنيون في هذا الامر ومقصود به
دون مشاركه العسكريين واضح ان هذه السلطه
بها كلاب مختلفه لا وجود لاي عسكريين فيها
يعني سير اسال قائد العام للجيش السوداني
العلاقه بين القائد الاعلى وبين هذه
القوات النظاميه همم كل لديه اختصاصات
لديه اعمال محدده ومكتوب
ولا احد يتجاوزها يعني لا يمكنهم تعيين
مثلا قائد عام الجيش
اذا مفصول الامر
بتوصيه من القوات المسلحه همم
الاخرى لديها اليات لتعيين القيادات
لتعيين الوظائف القياديه همم هو
مفهوم من القاعده الاعلى انه يوافق او
يصدق علامات تاتي من توصيات في كل
المجالات اذا كانت عدليه وعسكريه وقانونيه
ولا يتخذ زي همم اجراءات تنفيذيه وانما
الموافقه والتصدير على ما يرفع اليه من
تواصل
خلال الفتره المقبله
وحاول ان همم
الجيش العظيم الجيش الذي
جلسنا في هذا المجلس
تحدث عن الاصلاح العسكري هل هذا يعني
تعيين ضباط واقاله اخرين او ما هو المفهوم
لي للاصلاح العسكري الذي ينوي الفريق اول
عبد الفتاح البرهان القيام
بهذا الاصلاح من الفتره عيدنا تنظيم
القوات المسلحه من الشعار شعار القوات
المسلحه همم اجرينا عليه تعديل يتناسب مع
مطلوباتنا كسودانيين ما يتماشى مع عقيدتنا
ومع همنا الوطني همم ايضا تنظيم القاعده
في الفتره السابقه كان وزير الدفاع مثلا
جزء من المنظومه العسكريه الان وزير
الدفاع اصبح خارج الهيكل العسكري هنالك
تعديلات كثيره في القوانين حتى الدخول
لكليه الحربيه عملنا عليه بعض التعديلات
السمن الفرص بين تعليم السودان وولاياته
ايضا نراجع همم تشكيل القوات وحوجتنا لها
حاجتنا الاسلحه المراجعه الامور الاساسيه
التي تبني القوات المسلحه على حديثه تمكن
من ادامها
اليوم ايضا انت تحدثت في خطابك بان الجيش
سيخرج من العمليه السياسيه والقوه
السياسيه ايضا لا تشارك في الحكومه
الانتقاليه يعني باي معيار ربما او
اعتقد ان مطلوبات الفتره الانتقاليه يجب
لا تخضع للمحاصه
في الفتره الانتقاليه
وهو انك تاتي عن طريق تفويض الشعب الان لا
يوجد تفويض لا يزيد او لا يجيها حتى تحكم
لذلك من المفضل انه الحكومه تكون من
المستقلين الذين ليس لديهم
انتماءاتسابقه كان فئه تمكين لبعض الاحزان
كان فيها تجاوز وفي استخدام صلاحيات
لتقديم بعض الاحزاب او بعض الفئات ليس
جميعهم ولكن هنالك بعضهم اي والنبعد عنهم
هذه الشبهات استغلال الوظيفه او استغلال
السلطه لخدمه اذا كانت حزبيها او ايا كان
هذه الخدمه المطلوبه لذلك وهذا مطلب
الشارع اظن ان همم الشباب الموجودين الان
في الشارع كانت لديه مطالب واضح
جاء رئيس وزراء مدني ما هو عفوا سياسي ما
هو موقفك اذا توافقت القوى السياسيه على
هذا الامر
وكان يمكن ان
يقدم السودان ويقدم الدوله السودانيه
لا اظن ان هنالك مانع لكن نحن نفضل من لا
يكون من القوه السياسيه الواضحه لانه حتى
شركانا واخواننا في القوى السياسيه كنا
نتحاور معهم هم ملتزمين بان لا يكون هنالك
منهم من يشارك في هذه السلطه ولا حتى من
كان مشارك في الحكومه السابقه لكن
الكفاءات الوطنيه همم يمكن ان يكون هناك
بعض الحويه لبعض الشخصيات لا غير في ذلك
حزبيه
لكان هنالك ضروره لا ماني اعظم
حكومه مدنيه جديده واليوم انتم تتفائلون
بهذا الاتفاق الايطالي
[موسيقى]
حول ما طرح الموضوعات ااا ستعقب وتشكيل
الحكومه بالتاكيد
المسلحه اليوم لاحظنا تصريحات حاده من
جبريل ابراهيم ومني مناوي ان هذا الاتفاق
اتفاق اقصائي الان هم جزء من الحكومه كيف
يستقيم ان تستمر هذه الحكومه الانتقاليه
وفيها كل هذه المشاحنات همم اطراف
مثبته في مشاركه في السلطه
وانا اظن همم انهم همم
بالطريق او المسافه بين ما موقوف في هذا
الاتفاق وبين روائهم وافكارهم ليست بعيده
ايوه يمكن بقليل من الجود ان تتجذر هذه
الهوى وهذه المسافه وهمم نوحدوا جهدهم مع
بقيه زملائي
اريد ان اسالك سعاده الفريق اول عبد
الفتاح البرهان عن خلافات يعني طفت على
السطح خلال الفتره الماضيه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
ظللتم تنفون هذه الخلافات ولكنها موجوده
ما هو ما هي الدلالتك على انها موجوده هذه
الخلافات تروج لها جهات
معلومه للجميع ان هنالك بعض القوه
السياسيه والقوه الايدلوجيه والحزبيه التي
لا تريد ان تتوحد هذه القوه ايضا هنالك
مخاوف من توحد هذه القوه من مختلفه همم
الفاعلين اذا كانوا سياسيين او لديهم جنده
لكن احنا في القياده مقتنعين تماما بان
هذه الامور كلها مصنعه وليست حقيقيه نحن
كلنا شركاء في الهم الوطني وعندنا هدف
واحد انه نحمي هذا السودان هي كانت لدي هي
تصريحات وتلميحات النائبه الاول اخر هذه
التلميحات ان هناك من يصلون الى القصر
الجمهوري
ويسمح لهم وهناك من يمنع بان يصلوا وهو
يقصد طبعا تظاهرات كانت ضده وصلت الى
القصر
بين الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه
ايضا الذي
اثار الوكالات الحديثه عن التسليح الدعم
السريع
كل الامور التي تتم اظن تتم بالطرق
الشرعيه
اذا يعني انت لا
غير متضايق او غير مهتم بما يثار من حديث
عن الخلاف بينك وبين نائبك محمد حمدان
دلوله
[موسيقى]
القوه كلها ستضع في ايييييه قالب واحد في
معون واحد وهو القوات المسلحه اذا
كان في تسليح اذا كان في تدريب اذا كان في
كل شيء كله في النهايه سيصف في مصلحه
السودان
جوه لديه بعض المطبات لديه بعض الخطوات
والاجراءات
اللي عندنا فيها تجارب سابقه ومتى يتم اا
بدايه الدم وما ينتهي هذا الدم هذه الامور
ليست صعبه وليست معقده
وسنتمكن من بسهوله هناك بعض العسكريين
داخل مجلس السياده ما هي وضعيتهم مثل
كباشي العطاء جابر القوات المسلحه
ايضا سعاده الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
يعني همم
نتحدث الان عن قوه سياسيه همم تهدد باغلاق
الشرق وهمم باحداث ربما بعض البلبله في
الولايات السودانيه رفضا لهذا الاتفاق كيف
كيف ستقابلون هذا الامر
هذا الاتفاق تم التضليل المتعمد حول
مضمونه هنالك جهات لا يهمها ان يتم اي
توافق هنالك مستفيده من الوضع الهش او
كانت الفتره السابقه همم لذلك عندما يطلع
هذا الاتفاق وتتم تداوله وتدارسه يقتنع
بان هذا الاتفاق ما في مضر لاي جهه ما في
اي جهه متضرره بل فيه وكاسب للسودانيين
ويحقق كثير من المصالح الوطنيه التي
ننتظرها نحن ننتظر حتى اصحاب المصلحه اذا
كانوا في الشريك او في الغرب او في اي
مكان تحدث فيه بعض النزاعات السؤال الاخير
ربما كانت هناك جهود للاله الثلاثيه واللج
رباعيه ارغب ان اسالك عن الدور السعودي
ربما في همم احداث هذا الاتفاق وهذا
التوافق خاصه يعني ان هناك كانت لقاءات
ايضا تعقد في منزل السفير السعودي
منها جمع على اطراف ليست هنالك شروط ولا
يملاءات كانت المقاصد ان تجتمع الاطراف
وتلتقي وكانت هنالك ربما بعض ال- ال-
الحوافذ المستقبليه لانه اذا كان هذا
الامر تم يمكن ان ينعكس اجابه على
السوداني وعلى الشعب السوداني وعلى هذه
التنظيمات لكن لا شروط لا املاءات وهذا
كان سوداني نحنا كلنا اذا كان عسكريين او
مدنيين سياسيين همم نعرف المحاذير الامن
الوطني نعرف سيا هذا الوطنيه نعرف ما يطير
وما يصلح لذلك لا اظن ان هناك من تدخل في
هذا الامر كل هذا الامر رؤيه له مجموعات
تريد ان تفسيره
شكرا لك سعاده الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
البرهان على هذه الافادات